[Music]
and copyright news oh oh
JK news all of our channel we be getting
hit with that [ __ ] submitted by sticky
had to be Steve first just to make it
sound cute yep what would we need naive
oh yeah that's stupid Steven stinky okay
YouTube CEO Susan Wojcicki is urging
creators to protest European copyright
laws to protest European copyright laws
why what's what's the European copyright
laws I know cuz it's like who cares what
American right yeah but we can still get
hit I still want to hear it we can still
get hit with them yeah so um there's
this so he use new directive on
copyright
so you European Union so jetski she's
focusing on specifically article 13
which will be making tech platforms
liable for copyright protected content
instead of it so the individual so
that's why she's like okay say one more
time so instead of the individual
getting in trouble for copyright
infringement the platforms that they
uploaded it to gets in trouble you to
were gonna turn yeah
that's why she wants us to produce yeah
protects her ass oh no I like it that
way
well the thing is is that so she's
saying that if that does happen
YouTube's gonna shut down know that
YouTube will no longer be it would be
way too risky for YouTube to host like
individual creator content because it's
just too risky so they're only gonna be
hosting like big media corporations that
they know what they want anyway I know
that's what they're doing already why
can't they bring back the partner
program which is like what they had back
in the day where you apply for it and
there's only like you know you had to
get the filtered and they vetted the
people that were monetizing bit videos I
like that and so yeah so then it's like
we filled this trust and then if they
don't [ __ ] up then they get to keep
making their content but if they have a
couple strikes then you're out of the
program
right during that time though their
business model was failing they didn't
make enough money so that's why they
just went monetized crazy and they let
anybody just monetize video um I
remember they would put ads on people's
videos but you just couldn't get the
revenue for it unless you were in the
program is that is that right that's
right yeah people people's videos were
getting monetized and they won't even
getting paid yeah like I had ads on my
videos but I didn't get the money for it
because I wasn't in the program or the
partner yes ma'am but yeah so now
they're saying well it said she was
writing on this blog post where she's
urging people like in Europe
specifically to like protest this and
hopefully the lawmakers will change the
wording so that tech companies aren't
liable for this copyright infringement I
get her point though cuz it's almost
like imagine if a radio station right
like for us power 106 it'd be [ __ ] up
that power 106 gets in trouble for one
of the artists that they play those are
the real radio still no I'm just making
an example but like if if some like
let's say Jay Cole copies someone and
power 106 gets in trouble verses and
power 106 gets shut down instead of Jay
Cole being in trouble for copywriting
someone else yeah that's like if I
upload a picture on Facebook and its
copyright and Facebook gets sued so I
see where they're coming Twitter it
could be any platform they're even
saying here the article 13 could also
threaten people's abilities to post like
memes or parodies to because it's just
all like copyrights that like they're
just completely being hard on the
copyright yeah and then so she thinks I
mean that's cool I think like whoever
created that meme if it goes viral they
should benefit somehow instead of it
just being passed along the way it is no
she's talking about if you use
copyrighted material to create a meme
yeah you can't use that
oh yeah sure yeah that's I mean that's
the way it is in Hollywood you have to
pay for their likeness
well no but that fat falls under fair
use because if you're parroting
something or if you're covering it then
it's okay yeah but in this case what
she's saying is that that meme will no
longer be okay for a pair like the fair
it won't fall under fair use really
because if it's Europeans probably have
their own fair use act well that's the
reason yeah that's the whole thing here
like for the European Union's new laws
like the article yeah and so Susan was
saying like that's the reason why
YouTube created Content ID so then they
could protect the content owners but
like I automatically compare the content
of new videos to this database of
copyright video and audio and then it
lets copyright holders decide whether or
not they want to block that video that
has their copyright things in there so
that's what she was like that's the
reason why we have this on YouTube
already yeah so yeah that's pretty much
the whole thing here so she's just
saying everyone in European everyone in
Europe to protest this thing so
hopefully they can be they can change
the route they can reword it so it won't
be this bad yeah cuz do you think
Europe's just trying to control YouTube
or the platforms then instead of like
you think it's do you think that's the
motive or you think it was just a poorly
written well they're saying that that
this not that this legislation is
necessary to protect fair pay for
creators and that major tech companies
that they've just been like getting off
like just wiping their hands clean of
responsibility for too long I say like
they should be responsible for this
that's what the people for this are
saying okay I see that point too if you
have like a major corporation like let's
say Sony or something and they have like
a really big record Google well what's
gonna happen is they don't want to deal
with the lawsuits so they're just gonna
block us out like this is what happened
when ad pocalypse yeah yeah is that they
don't want to deal with it so anything
that might even like be a glimpse of
dangerous risky thing like they're gonna
do monetize yeah I mean like I saw
somebody with a with the family pumpkin
patch video get demonetised and like
there's just
[ __ ] that's getting demonetised cuz it
was like Barba Brigade new launch chute
hey that's probably because I shoot guns
yeah and because it's a bot like that
God to monetize and I'm like what the
[ __ ] it's just a fashion thing and
they're gonna use BOTS because there's
just an photo shoot have a question when
you upload your family vlogs you know
how it has that new thing where it's
like is there a minor in the video yeah
do you check that box
[Music]
we don't even upload our videos ask the
person that does I don't even know what
happens if you check that box I have no
idea cuz I've never had a minor my
videos really well it says something
about like the parent needs to have
permission I mean they're the parents
yeah I just was curious what happens
when you check their box
you're like money already make less
money or does it ask you more questions
I'm curious
go check the box I should be honest I'm
like nope can't check it until I have a
kid in there I feel like I've checked it
I don't know what's happened I guess I
don't you make more money from check
nothing kind of look I don't I do it
based off of the money that's smart yeah
I miss old YouTube me to everyone knows
about old YouTube it's old Instagram -
yeah - it was like more freedom
it felt free and the Creator is all like
supportive of each other because I
weren't that many of them and they're
like everyone was like everyone was
trying to do other things so like people
were musicians or directors or actors or
whatever and they were creating content
and now people just want to be famous so
they just like kind of yeah that's like
drama channels and I think they painted
the pureness of it right yeah yeah and
it's just like the things that don't
have skill are getting rewarded more
than like people that create like art
like I know some so talented musicians
that can't get their videos to get seen
and all these other videos get pushed to
the top that are just like trash videos
maybe another type of YouTube will come
back I really come out yeah or a start
some competitor yeah like Instagram
stories is kind of a little
like that a little bit but they don't
monetize I know though the problem is
that nowhere else monetizes I love your
one eye I can only see one of her eyes
right now but I feel like if Instagram
upped their game and then they started
you know paying these creators all
because I much rather be on Instagram
yeah I do
I'm connected to my phone you know
instead of carrying a another camera
they wanted it to be that way
they just need it to get popular first
no not as popular GTV now they're
starting to show it on on explore page
IG TV oh really
yeah I'm talking about IG TV they want
to monetize but they needed to get
popular sucks and that's what you need
about it it's it's a it's a whole
difference that I have to watch it like
that you check another app too
yeah I know it's not another op but it's
just a different step that you have you
go into it like yeah whereas with the
story it's just it's clear you you play
it it's just and it just it all plays
one after the other it's just easier
yeah I guess I could see TV the same
though cuz it's like you so it's still
in the top you still click on it and
it's like it plays act one after the
other it's just not as engaging cuz like
it only shows one person's at the top
and I don't usually want to see that
whatever it is think that when people
are on YouTube they're there to watch a
20 minute video a 15 minute video when
I'm on my phone and I'm scrolling I want
to see any time yeah like okay this is
cool and then you have point to segments
to get my attention I don't want to sit
there for 20 minutes watching a video
yeah maybe Facebook they're trying to
monetize to well you still use Facebook
no but a lot so people were leaving
Instagram for snapchat and then
Instagram came out with stories and then
everyone came back over to Instagram I
feel like Facebook if they started
monetizing videos they might be able to
develop a platform where people actually
do yeah they do but it's not like much
money and the CPMs are very very largely
low I'm not a fan of the layout though
like the Facebook layout like it just
Facebook watch huh yeah it just looks
like a [ __ ] of things that
there's just so much going on things
yeah but I'm like just chill the [ __ ]
out dude I clean it a lot of [ __ ]
there's too many ads I don't even know
what Facebook looks like exactly the
same
it's like when myspace got so many ads
put on it and then everyone's like my
yeah this is wild man I think um
Facebook is different though now that it
evolved a little bit in the way that you
use it so like back when we used it it
was a little bit more seclude like it
was it was like just exclusive like our
friends and maybe like young people and
now like everyone's on it and now older
people are on it to college is like you
can only get an account if you had a
school account but now I've been back on
it because if you have like 10,000 fans
and you uploaded a few videos and all
these things then they let you be a part
of this program I have that huh yeah and
then and then like you can just let it
monetize and all that I'll segregate it
just like how we were talking about IG
TV how you have to go to like messenger
app and like pages and yeah hey
different apps I'm like I just want to
be on one end yeah it took me like
several days to get used to but you
could create like these different clubs
and groups and like it's it's a really
good way to kind of like get your fans
and have access to them cuz like you
have Instagram and all that but you're
[ __ ] by the algorithm right right and
a nice book [ __ ] you with the algorithm
too like they only show your content to
like a small portion of your fans no but
if you talk to them in your group and
then now there's BOTS and that's the
whole new thing is like instead of doing
emails now people are doing chat BOTS
right yeah so you if you get people to
come talk to you on your chat BOTS it
and sign up and now if you want to blast
a message here's a new video or whatever
it goes direct into their facebook
Messenger and then that has a higher
chance of them clicking and reading it
than their email or Twitter or like they
might miss that idea about yeah so then
I I'm testing this out right now and
it's pretty good like the open rate is
really high and the engagement is really
high and it's pretty fun because I
turned a little game into the
conversation so it's like they know it's
a bot but then it's fun to interact yeah
oh my god it's just it's a lot yes my
head hurts already same
just gotta traditional careers it's
easier you should play never told me
never
I'd rather tattoo my entire face then go
back to that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]